you have been all over the world yeah or  this worldwide premiere it's got to be  blowing your mind exhaust it's  exhausting  yeah they pushed this show pony too far  they pushed each other  yeah well yeah you sent a video to us  just about I want to say like two hours  ago that sort of demonstrates how loopy  you were getting from all the problem is  that what we're so this was my first  night of sleep I couldn't sleep in the  hotels cause like we were so turned  around we were in a new country every so  the best night of sleep on the whole  tour I got was on the plane and it was  about 12 hours and I actually dislocated  my toe  right you were so thrilled this is this  is a video okay to my toe by hitting my  own foot yeah that can happen that's  very hard to do is it purple really do  they're okay yeah yesterday we have this  is video that someone on the plane took  of you getting your first 12 hours of  sleep this is how excited you were  [Applause]